[Music]
there is growing outrage
and concern about women's safety in
britain
after the killing of a woman this
morning london police are being
denounced for using
force to control the weekend vigil over
the death of sarah everard the
33-year-old disappeared on her way home
late at night a police officer is
charged with kidnapping
and murder as holly williams reports
protesters
say too many women are at risk and
they've had enough
[Music]
angry protesters gathered outside
britain's houses of parliament last
night
sarah everard's killing has touched a
nerve in this country
igniting grief but also frustration
that women must still fear for their
lives on the street
like the ladies these students told us
it could have happened to them
two years maybe after me too movement we
thought that maybe we've made some
progress
with women's rights women being safe
well actually
i think the murder made us realize that
we're not we're not actually there
sarah everard was last seen walking home
along well-lit roads
a week later her remains were found and
a serving police officer was charged
with her murder
sarah was strong and principled her
family said in a statement
a shining example to us all with the
most amazing
sense of humor dead women is a thing
we've all just
accepted as part of our daily lives in
parliament one lawmaker read out the
names of women killed here in the last
year
where a man has been convicted or
charged williams
118 of them kelly fitzgibbons
killed alongside her two daughters at
this makeshift memorial near where sarah
disappeared there was a vigil on the
weekend
even kate the duchess of cambridge made
a private visit to lay flowers
but later on saturday night the police
tried to break up the crowd
[Applause]
the vigil was against lockdown rules but
their heavy-handed tactics
and these images have horrified the
nation
and helped fuel more protests last night
[Music]
sexist police off our streets they
shouted
this time the police officers just stood
and watched
the government here has now called for a
review into police tactics used at the
vigil
the uk is one of the most gender equal
countries in the world
but 97 percent of women aged 18 to 24
here
say they've been sexually harassed
according to new research
gail oh my gosh holly williams that is
very disturbing
very disturbing statistics thank you so
much so many questions in that case
did the officer know her not know her
was random
also questions in the tactics that they
used to break into protest but that is a
that is a huge protest yes those numbers
are
really huge really troubling